enfants
isabelle boulay fait un malheur avec son
nouvel album de noël et les numéros un
les gens aiment ces chansons là parce
que c'est des chansons qui sont pour la
plupart soit joyeuse au réconfortante
pendant ce temps l'album country
héritage de noël de rené turgeon
il fait son apparition au top 10
francophone est le premier album de noël
de mariah carey paru en 1994 est revenue
dans le top 30 anglophone
[Musique]
ç'a toujours été un succès dans
l'industrie de la musique quand on fait
croire ces deux industries ans dans le
contexte d'une société de consommation
et on sait que les gens consomment
beaucoup à noël selon une étude
américaine parmi tous les amateurs de
musique de noël 8% aux moins de 18 ans
36% sont des millénaires you 31% sont de
la génération x et 25% ont 55 ans et
plus
[Musique]
ça nous remet dans l'ambiance et la
musique nous rappelle comme agence ça va
déclencher les mémoires des dents tout à
fait c'est comme les chiens pavlov c'est
un conditionnement
va voir
cosma
ici encore aujourd'hui on écoute le
white christmas que chantait dans les
années 40
bing crosby c'est parce que les
classiques de noël refuse de mourir
l'être humain a tendance à aimer ce qui
a déjà entendu ce qui a déjà connu donc
peut-être ça explique pourquoi les gens
vont remettre
année après année les 10 que leur disque
de noël préféré ne
c'est un chez lui
[Applaudissements]
aimez vous la musique d'honneur oui
j'aime la musique de noël beaucoup en
france
la musique de noël n'ont demandé aux
coffee shops pour les musiques de noël
en ce moment c'est par isabelle boulay
qui n'en démord pas les chansons de noël
sont là pour rester
les chansons ne laissent des empreintes
ce peut-être plus indélébile et je pense
que c'est pour ça qu'elle continue de
perdurer ici wifi depuis mai radio
canada
[Musique]
est ce vrai